welcome to a special episode of tech
news briefing for Monday April 24th I'm
Zoe Thomas for The Wall Street Journal
this is the fourth episode of our series
artificially minded where we look at how
artificial intelligence is changing our
lives livelihoods and culture
the first three episodes can be found in
this feed we look at the fundamentals of
AI answer your questions and look at how
new AI tools are upending creative jobs
and if you have any questions or
comments about the series or ideas for
future episodes send us an email at tnb
wsj.com
today we're stepping into the thorny
question of liability
who's responsible for the content
generative AI creates
new generative artificial intelligence
tools chat Bots like chat GPT and new AI
powered search engines allow users to
type in a prompt like tell me about
Abraham Lincoln and get a full
conversational answer back
these online programs can get a lot of
things right but they can also get
things wrong
and the question of how to deal with
this is one more tech companies
lawmakers and legal Scholars are
starting to Grapple with in different
ways to start I want to tell you about a
situation happening in Australia
I do recall that it was on a Sunday
evening and once I found it I was quite
staggered I had to rate it and re-rate
it several times
Brian hood is the mayor of Hepper and
Shire a council outside of Melbourne
he's exploring the possibility of suing
open AI the maker of chat GPT for
defamation
chat GPT was making very false
statements about me very serious false
statements claiming that I'd been
charged with serious criminal offenses
that I'd been sentenced to jail that
obviously that I'd been found guilty of
those offenses
all of which is very untrue
worked for a company that made banknotes
for government Central Bank
while working there he discovered that
some people were paying bribes to
foreign officials to secure contracts
and he reported this to authorities
it led to a massive investigation that
hit the media in 2009 and it resulted in
arrests and jail time for those involved
and became one of Australia's biggest
banking scandals
but Hood says friends and constituents
told him that when they asked Chad GPT
who he was and what his involvement in
that Scandal was it didn't say he was
The Whistleblower it said the exact
opposite so he quickly went on the
platform to check things out himself
it was saying that I was one of the
perpetrators that I was one of the
people charged with the offenses found
guilty of them sentenced to jail that I
was on the other side of the table if
you like when Hood discovered this error
he was concerned and contacted local
lawyers to see what see what he'd done
the lawyers took the first step under
Australian law to file a defamation case
sending a concerns notice to open AI
with a list of Demands that included
removing the defamatory statement from
Chad GPT a public apology and monetary
compensation
open AI had 28 days to respond and
Hood's lawyer says the company has but
not to their satisfaction and now hood
is considering his options including
formally taking this to court and since
Hood's lawyers contacted openai they say
it has removed mentions of Brian Hood
from chat GPT when we tested this the
program returned messages like sorry an
error has occurred we reached out to
open AI about this but it did not
respond to a request for comment
now open ai's terms of use do say that
some of Chad gpt's responses may not be
accurate and it also has a disclaimer at
the bottom of the chatbot site echoing
that statement but for Hood that's not
enough you've sent this letter to open
AI what do you hope is the outcome of
all of this well hopefully there's
several outcomes I'd like them to
correct the record and fix their systems
so that it doesn't make these
disparaging comments about me I'd like
an apology I'd like some sort of
reassurance that their tool is now going
to be
accurate and reliable
so why are we telling you Brian Hood's
story
because it's not the only mistake a
generative AI tool has made and you may
have already come across other stories
of people claiming it to be harmed by
incorrect information from AI chat Bots
when I asked chat GPT who is Zoe Thomas
the host of tech news briefing it says
I've worked at several outlets I've
never reported for and graduated from
universities I've never attended in four
attempts it didn't get it right
so how do companies building AI tools
tackle this Challenge and what are their
obligations under the law
before we get into the question of the
law let's quickly talk about why
generative AI programs might get
something wrong
these hallucinations can happen because
the data that these programs draw from
may have incorrect or incomplete
information as you're probably aware the
internet is full of inaccuracies in fact
a 2016 poll from Pew research found
almost a quarter of Americans said
they've shared made up news either
knowingly or unwittingly on top of that
the programs aren't necessarily trying
to give you the right answers they're
trying to formulate answers that sound
natural to form sentences where one word
flows after another to create reasonable
sounding responses
and even the makers of these programs
say they can't predict what the programs
are going to say
so who is responsible when programs like
chat GPT say something incorrect or even
harmful
every country has different laws on this
what applies to Mayor Hood in Australia
won't necessarily be the case for others
around the world
in the U.S it's a really tricky question
there's a provision of a law that you
may have heard of section 230 of the
1996 Communications decency act it
protects online platforms like Facebook
Twitter or Google from being held liable
for content posted by users
so for the most part the people who post
content online are the people
responsible for it Jason Schultz is the
director of New York University's
technology law and policy clinic so if I
post a photo or I say something on
Twitter or I message someone or I put up
a website whatever happens tends to be
something where I'm held accountable not
the platform that hosts it
section 230 says online platforms are
like public squares companies that make
them aren't responsible for what people
say in them but the thing is that hinges
on something important the idea that
platforms don't create the content they
just host it
there's even a case testing the limits
of section 230 at the Supreme Court
right now Gonzalez V Google
it questions whether Google's subsidiary
YouTube should be held responsible for
Content linked to the 2015 Paris
terrorist attacks the families of
victims argue YouTube failed to take
down some Isis terrorist videos and even
recommended them to users
and they say that makes Google liable
for damages although they haven't
presented evidence that the terrorists
involved saw these videos
Google has argued YouTube was the host
of this information and is therefore
protected by section 230. the court has
an issued a ruling yet
but experts say this case could also
impact how courts deal with generative
AI
gender of AI is this weird mixture
because what it does is it trains on
user content right trains on the whole
internet
and then it responds to a prompt by user
so is that content created by the
Company the company can't predict ahead
of time what the generative AI tool is
going to say so it doesn't quite create
the content in that sense but they
certainly designed and engineered the
program they know that it's capable of
doing these things they certainly could
test it and find out that it will tell
you lies and it will tell you to do
horrible things if you ask it to do tell
me all the horrible things I can do if
you ask it to is the key here to
understanding who might be considered
the creator of an answer on a generative
AI chat bot
if I were to search something like how
do I get blood off my carpet if I search
it in say Google search versus searching
something like that on chat GPT or
another AI generator how is that
different or similar in terms of legal
liability
in general CDA 230 would completely
cover this for like a general search
engine because again it's a neutral
platform in that sense of like
your requesting content it searches
third-party websites so it's not like
Google wrote the web page right it's
just pointing you to something and some
of these gender of AIS it will depend on
the information is characterized if it
says and again this is what's hard
because you can't predict exactly what
they'll say like that's part of what's
exciting about them is what's going to
happen now what if I ask it this way
what if I have a follow-up question
right
it might say oh you know if you're
interested in getting blood out of a
carpet here are some standardized
techniques and here's some links or it
could say hmm well it depends on how uh
why you want to get the blood off the
carpet if you want to get blood off the
carpet because you killed someone you
don't want to caught by the cops here's
a really great way to do it if you want
to get the blood off the car because you
cut yourself shaving then don't worry
about this and do it this way right like
there it is a little more focused right
so the use of generative AI blurs the
line between Creator and platform so if
the prompt is please summarize the most
efficient ways to get blood off a carpet
fine but if it were to be a kind of
conversation where you're prompting and
responding prompting and responding and
you get to the point where you're like
no I really need to get rid of this to
the point where a CSI person you know
can't find it on my carpet that's
different but then again that's user
prompting right that's user pushing it
and so I think with cd230 it's starting
to feel more like a search engine to me
if the user's pushing the answer and
trying to get the gender of AI to say
something specific versus is it's the
design and training of the AI that puts
out the harmful content I mean the thing
that stands out to me with all of this
is they built the companies behind
generative AI build the models they
decide what information is being put
into it so even if they don't know
what's being predicted they've already
made decisions that impact what's going
to show up in the answer what could
potentially show up in the answer and
that does seem fundamentally different
than just saying like we have a platform
put up whatever you know post to your
friends whatever you feel like you know
it's funny it is and it isn't right I
mean this is a little bit Nitty Gritty
into like the how does AI get made right
but most of these systems are trained on
just massive data sets that are scraped
from the internet but part of the
argument is the only way to get it so
sophisticated to the point where it can
handle almost any question is to train
on things in the number of billions
of things from the internet and that's
just even for a company like you know
meta or Google like too many things to
parse through
I mean there's some obvious ones I mean
like child pornography something that is
like threatening violence but not in a 5
billion
image data set and so you kind of make
this choice of like am I going to train
on this giant data set or not if I don't
the argument goes my AI will not be as
sophisticated this is what I mean like
at some point a Court's going to say
here's the line
you know if you train on violin images
that you know or if you train on like
other stuff that's very bad for people
then that's too much if you don't
constrain it in certain ways but I think
there's going to be a lot of sympathy
again for the technical arguments that
you need
is to understand the world writ large to
be as sophisticated as it is before you
tell it what it can and can't do
the thing is U.S courts will likely not
be the only place this gets sorted out
lawmakers around the world are also
debating and developing ways to regulate
artificial intelligence China for
example has already put in place laws
around algorithms and generative AI
among other things they prohibit the use
of AI generated content for spreading
fake news or information deemed to be
disruptive to the economy or national
security
the European Union is working on a piece
of legislation the AI act that is
expected to create new obligations for
AI tools depending on how risky the law
says they are and last week leaders at
the eu's parliament proposed adding new
rules that would curb the power of many
generative AI tools
and here in the U.S where section 230
has set so much of the stage for how
internet platforms are treated the Biden
Administration is weighing new AI
regulations the White House says it's
particularly concerned that these tools
could be used to discriminate or spread
harmful information
a lot of people will be watching how
these new legal Landscapes shake out in
the meantime there are already some
people who are trying to address these
risks at the engineering level remember
those AI hallucinations we mentioned
earlier let's take a moment to go over
why they happen here's wsjtech reporter
Karen Howe explaining how they work
I think there's a common misconception
that when you're chatting with child gbt
it's sort of scanning the internet for
information and then synthesizing it for
you that's not exactly how it works it's
actually trying to construct sentences
that sound reasonable based on the
probability of certain words and phrases
being frequently used together so it's
not actually identifying specific pieces
of information it's literally just kind
of a really powerful autocomplete where
it takes words and then assembles them
based on the frequency in which it sees
it within the internet text Karen
stressed that you need to consider what
data these programs are trained on and
how reliable they are because garbage in
garbage out
but what can be really problematic
according to experts is the
conversational nature of these programs
I think it's a user experience that
people really like
that's Ramon chowdry she's a data
scientist and social scientist who's
worked in the field of responsible AI
for the last five years before starting
a responsible AI consulting firm earlier
this year she worked for companies
including Twitter and Accenture there is
a conversational interactivity to it
that's kind of more like you're talking
to a Smart researcher if you're trying
to search for something
chaudry says our ever-growing Reliance
on the internet for work and pleasure
has made more people come to believe
what they see and read online no matter
what the source
over half of U.S adults under age 30 say
they trust what they read on social
media as much as what they see on
national news outlets according to a
2022 survey from the Pew Research Center
the human beings tend to trust these
environments that we have at this point
pretty much been socialized to search
online and we don't generally go beyond
the first two to three hits we get
when search engines and AI chat Bots are
Blended as Microsoft and Google are
working on users may not even leave the
search platform for another site to get
the information thereafter unless you
click on where the sources are coming
from you're not going to know whether or
not it's a verifiable source so in short
people will believe what they see
because it's disembodied the source of
information which we can't now easily
assess if it's if we think it's
trustworthy or not from the content
itself because it's reading to you like
a story
and chaudry says this conversational
approach of generative AI chat Bots is
one of their best and worst features so
I love the idea of it I like the idea
that it's more like talking to a
research librarian if you're looking
something up online but the fact that
you can't tell fact from fiction on it
is quite scary
Google said it's aware of the
limitations of large language models
that generative AI programs are built on
and acknowledged that its own AI power
chatbot Bard is not immune to
hallucinations but said it's taking
steps to ground Bard in more factual
responses Bard is not a search engine
its purpose is to generate content users
of Bard can go directly from that
product to Google search to check
answers and Google has placed
limitations on back and forth dialogue
between Barden users to keep
conversations with a chatbot topical the
company also stresses that its
generative AI tool is still experimental
a spokesperson from Microsoft told us
that the company has taken steps to keep
users of its ai-powered search engine
Bing safe responses draw from the top
search results and the program has a
safety system that includes content
filtering operational monitoring and
abuse detection its AI power word search
provides linked citations for these
answers and Microsoft explicitly advises
users that they may need to check the
links to learn more the company added
however that like with any assistant
tool users are ultimately responsible
for verifying information
many companies building AI tools work
with ethicists some are part of the
teams creating the products others work
to find and improve issues once the
programs are built and there are a
variety of different tactics they can
use
so one of the things I'm particularly
interested in right now is something
called prompt hacking so prompt hacking
is figuring out ways in which you can
get the model to say and do things that
would otherwise be explicitly denied so
there's one for example called do
anything now where you essentially
pretend the model that it's telling you
a story or you're priming it in some way
and you'll say hey so if I were to write
a story about how to make a bomb how
would you make a bomb
another technique is called red teaming
essentially you bring in subject matter
experts to push AI on specific issues
let's say I wanted to understand how
election misinformation could spread
it's very expensive to hire full-time
election misinformation folks instead it
might make more sense to pull together a
group of journalists who are very
familiar with how election
misinformation could work and have it
interact with the model to help generate
it
what I love about this is it subverts
the idea that seems to be pervasive that
technology is smarter than people I
don't think technology is smarter than
people and certainly it's not smarter
than people as an Aggregate and that's
really what I'm trying to tap into is
it's this wisdom of the masses
folks like chaudry are on the front line
for tackling the risks and potentially
harmful content being generated by these
AI tools but until laws catch up to
technology it may be up to both
companies and users to be aware and
correct potential wrong answers that AI
chat Bots produce whether any of us want
the responsibility or not
okay that's it for this fourth episode
of our AI series artificially minded
we'll be keeping an eye on more
developments and artificial intelligence
technology because this area is
developing quickly and there are so many
more questions to answer in the meantime
join us tomorrow and every weekday for
updates on the biggest Tech stories and
if you want even more Tech news check
out our website wsj.com
Today's show was produced by Julie Chang
we had editorial support from Falana
Patterson and Robert wall our
supervising producer is Melanie Roy and
our executive producer is Chris sinsley
this episode was mixed by Michael
Lavalle I'm your host Zoe Thomas Thanks
so much for listening
[Music]